all right dane dunning we do know him
these are the numbers from last year's
seven starts 34 innings
34 strikeouts so dunning the head of the
count of ball and two strikes
on marcus simeon the lead off man for
the blue jays and that strike three
called
great start for dane dunning a couple of
quick outs and now beau buchet hitting
in the three spot again
as now machete swings lifts a high fly
ball left field
deep and gone four or five rows deep
into the
seats in left first home run of the
season for beshette
one to nothing blue chase boy oh boy he
is so quick inside watch how quickly he
rotates his hips
and he knows he got it all he has the
pleasure of standing there watching
it oscar hernandez right fielder and
cleanup man
for the blue jays dunning's 3-2 on the
way
and tay oscar hits it hard and back up
the box into center field for a base hit
so now vladimir guerrero jr
that one's in the air should in the
inning
condor underneath it and guzman clamps
the glove
shut inning done the blue jay santana
roared to the bow for the first time
this season
isaiah kiner falefa the shortstop for
the rangers leads it off
bouncer left side of the infield and
that one gets through biggio
just kind of olayed that out in the left
and connor falefa
is on to start the first shall we gallow
the hitter
gallows skies one and you can see how
disappointed he is
will it stay and play for guerrero it
will in a big second out
ten rbis for nate in the first four
games the new
rangers franchise record payoff pitch
and that one in the air center field
that's going to be trouble
back to the wall gone tina rohar thought
he could throw another fastball for
seymour now nate lowe was
late on a couple but that one right on
time
see his eyes light up he drills this
baseball
that is an impressive home run in this
ball second home run of the year for
nate lowe
he now has 12 rbis
kurt getting the start today he's old
for four
nice there's strike three called kirk
down looking it was a lot of work for
dunning
but he got it done and a 10 pitch at
back
ronald guzman will lead things off weird
journey
for guzman this last year and he hits
this ball hard
and it's on a long journey deep into the
bleachers
guzman's first home run of the season
it's 3-1 rangers
[Music]
well there is an advantage to having
long arms when you do get them extended
on a slider the way that ronald guzman
just did good to see that smile back
from goosey and that'll bring up the
number nine hitter
leote tavares did he go on that
curveball they appeal and he did
tavares strikes out and the inning is
over but not before a guzman home run
off roark makes it 3-1 texas
top of the order in the third inning for
toronto here's the one-two
swing and a foul tip and that's caught
by hyman so simeon is out on strikes for
a second
time dunning into the glove into his
motion and the o2
swinging a ground ball off the mound to
second scooped up by solak good throw to
first one two three go to jays
here in the third gallow popped up in
foul territory his first time up blue
jays stay in the shift pachette the only
infielder to the left of second
base and a swing into ground ball for
beshette to his right can't get it out
of his glove
as he tries to throw to second recovers
in time to get the out at first
on a close play but because of the the
difficulty there they don't get the lead
runner
he had it clean and just it was probably
thinking two or at least a shot at two
and so we rushed it
but didn't have a good grip on the
baseball we'll see if the rangers can
take advantage of
maybe that little extra that they get
here nate lowe
the two run homer in the first
ball in the air deep center field
he's done it again
and even nate lowe has to laugh a little
bit because he knows how ridiculous
he is right now and how on fire he is
right now and what is the earliest that
we've ever seen a statue built in a
player's
career because i think we're going to be
talking about nate lowe's april for a
long time hernandez then guerrero
and then guriel swing and a miss he
strikes out hernandez his
fifth strikeout of the night looks like
he may try to do it again
he got him back-to-back strikeouts
dunning looking very sharp
chopper down at first guzman with a good
feed to dunning and it's another quick
half of the fourth inning this time only
ten pitches needed
one and two on alejandro kirk
curt rolls this one up the middle solak
is there
and another one two three for dane
dunning
and he is in a groove right now
time was grounded out flat out and
there's a swing and there's a high drive
well hit to left
carrillo going back he's at the wall
that ball is history
a home run for jonah heim and for the
first time ever
the rangers have hit four home runs in a
game at globe life field
time's first home run coming on an 0-1
fastball toward the inside part of the
plate
barbecue for everybody carry out
just over two so far in this ball game
and the pitch
fastball grounded up the middle and into
center field to base it
guerrero will stop at second on the play
and the blue jays have a couple of men
on with one out one and one the count
did you on the way bounced in and off
the glove of heim
and the runners will take advantage and
advance now it'll be up to randall
gretchen
the first pitch from hearn down and in
gets away from home
runner coming home head first slide and
vladi is safe
into third on the play is gorielle and
the blue jays get a run out of it now
trailing six to two
richard waiting one one from hearn
fastball poked into right field of base
head
he has done it again gorielle into score
and it is six to three
well boy randall grichik looks like a
different hitter
a couple of quick outs and now beau
buchette
drills the ball left field it's gone
a line drive home run for boba shed
his second of the night in the blue jays
are within two
that looked like a breaking ball that he
timed up perfectly
one out now for brockholtz holt sends
that one into left field though that's a
base hit
here comes solac he'll score and hold
his driven in a big run
7-4 rangers in the eighth
such a solid approach here from
brockhole first of all
a really good at-bat against david
phelps they gained work fans here
ready to cheer on that first home win of
the year
in the air left field goal waiting on it
and the rangers pick up their first home
win of 2021.
ian kennedy with his first save as a
ranger
a 7-4 win over the toronto blue jays